some people in the world like to create
complexity some people in the world
Thrive under complexity like lawyers
right lawyers want the world to be more
complex because you need more lawyers
you need more legal hours right
um I think that's another if there's two
great evils in the world it's
centralization and complexity yeah and
uh the one of the sort of hidden
uh side effects of software engineering
is
uh like finding pleasure and complexity
I mean I don't remember just taking all
the software engineering courses and
just doing programming and this is just
coming up in this uh
uh object-oriented programming kind of
idea you don't like not often do people
tell you like do the simplest possible
thing like like a professor a teacher is
not going to get in front like this is
the simplest way to do it they'll say
like this is direct there's the right
way and the right way at least for a
long time you know especially I came up
with like Java right like is is if
there's so much boilerplate so much like
so many classes so many like designs and
architectures and so on like planning
for features far into the future and
planning poorly and all this kind of
stuff and then there's this like code
base that follows you along and puts
pressure on you and nobody knows what
like Parts different parts do which
slows everything down is the kind of
bureaucracy that's instilled in the code
as a result of that but then you feel
like oh well I follow good software
engineering practices it's an
interesting trade-off because then you
look at like the ghettowness of like
Pearl and the old like how quickly you
could just write a couple lines and just
get stuff done that trade-off is
interesting or bash or whatever these
kind of ghetto things you can do in
Linux one of my favorite things to look
at today is how much do you trust your
tests all right we've put a ton of
effort in comma and I put a ton of
effort in tiny grad into making sure if
you change the code and the tests pass
that you didn't break the code yeah now
this obviously is not always true
but the closer that is to true the more
you trust your tests the more you're
like oh I got a pull request and the
tests pass I feel okay to merge that the
faster you can make progress CEO is
programming with tests of mine
developing tests yeah with that in mind
that if it passes it should be good and
Twitter not that
so it was impossible to make progress in
the code base